perplexing thing about Einstein in
general relativistic gravitation that
still mystifies me and experts is that
when you add matter to the universe it
actually makes it expand faster which is
counterintuitive you would think if
there was more gravity in the Earth's
surface the ball would or the Apple
would actually fall down even quicker
which it would in the case of when we
described the expansion of the universe
we're talking about its velocity not its
acceleration so there's a crucial
distinction the universe can have
objects moving faster away from each
other and that doesn't involve
necessarily their acceleration so what
Einstein did to counteract that fact he
was a pretty smart guy right he looked
around he said well the universe doesn't
seem to be collapsing so there must be
some hidden form of energy that we don't
observe unobserved matter he called the
cosmological term we later call it the
cosmological constant and now we call it
dark energy as you proposed what that
does is by adding in matter you get
anti-gravity or you add an energy Pure
Energy you get a form of anti-gravity
I'm almost as if you know it's the comic
book Heroes a dream that you could
suspend gravity that you could freeze
the motion of objects that tend to want
to combine with one another so he then
had a mechanism contrived as it was to
explain why the universe appeared static
as it did in 1919 but then as I
mentioned earlier when Hubble observed
the universe is in fact not static hero
Einstein the universe is expanding then
Einstein had the Brilliance the humility
and the confidence to say I was wrong
and supposedly he called the insertion
of the cosmological term his biggest
blunder so the dark energy phenomenon
causes not only a reversal of the
collapse of the universe's in Fall of
all these galaxies or raisins that would
be coming together it not only freezes
them in their tracks it actually
reverses that process so instead of just
expanding linearly smoothly as Hubble
would Envision us doing actually the
universe starts to accelerate so it's as
if you're pushing down on the Cosmic
accelerator pedal these galaxies are not
only moving apart but tomorrow they'll
be moving apart even faster at a given
distance they'll be moving apart faster
than they are so I always joke you know
it was a blunder of Einstein to call
that blunder his blunder because it
wasn't a blunder at all and I always say
I like to throw in you know it's too bad
that he made that blunder otherwise he
could have had a good career
foreign
[Music]